what's happening in this forgotten
province of Northwest Syria represents a
huge escalation a haze of smoke rising
from the grounds marking a fresh wave of
bombings Syrian regime forces emboldened
and protected by Russian air cover a
widening their offensive the area's
mostly help bite area and Shack formerly
known as the looser affront and once an
offshoot of al Qaeda last year a deal
between Russia and Turkey created a
demilitarized zone from which the
jihadists were meant to retreat but the
Kremlin claims that's not happened which
is why we're now seeing Moscow's war
machine kicking up a gear Damascus sees
this as an opportunity to recover more
territory
President Assad indicating he'll pay the
price in spilt blood to regain every
inch of Syrian soil the bodies of dead
militants lie in the areas that have now
been taken back and anyone who's
witnessed the brutality of the Assad
regime will not doubt it's intense
deadly barrel bombs have been dropped
over this area causing huge numbers to
flee
many of these people are already
refugees of the Syrian conflict and now
they're being displaced again we ran
away from bombing it's destroyed
everything we're sewing to make a
shelter under the trees we are six
families and don't have anywhere to go
and no one is helping us at least 50
villages have been under the shelling
and aerial bombardment
if the conflagration broadens the
consequences will be devastating for the
region's 3 million residents a million
of them are children
we condemn the last of innocent civilian
lives and we are alarmed by the
displacement of over 150 thousand
persons as well as the targeting of
population centers and civilian
infrastructure including hospitals and
schools this offensive may be limited at
the moment but the danger of escalation
is very real and would represent a major
challenge to the international community
the UN is trying to calm the fighting
through diplomatic channels but the
warnings have so far been ignored
Alex Rossi Sky News